donc 60 50 de ce jumelage
ces discussions se sont déroulées dans
de bonnes conditions nous avons discuté
d'un certain nombre de points liés à
l'évolution de nos relations bilatérales
nous avons accordé une attention
particulière aux problèmes de
l'actualité internationale
j'ai déjà dit que l'allemagne est un des
partenaire clé de la russie nous avons
toujours cherché à renforcer la
coopération entre nos pays nous avons
l'impression que le chancelier est aussi
disposée à envisager une coopération
avec la russie cela concerne au premier
chef les relations économiques et
commerciales qui revêtent club
traditionnellement un caractère très
intensif et lâche la chine et occupe le
premier plan et l'allemagne est
justement au deuxième plan en matière de
partenariat commercial et malgré les
difficultés liées à la la pandémie et
aux difficultés de l'année 2021 notre le
volume de nos échanges a augmenté de 36%
pour atteindre 57 milliards de dollars
là les investissements allemands en
russie représentait 21 milliards et les
investissements russes en allemagne 10
milliards de dollars il ya plus de cas
l'an 4000 entreprises en russie qui ont
un capital en partie en partie allemands
et les plus grandes entreprises
allemandes sont présentes ici sur notre
marché et ces échanges vont être
poursuivies et c'est la vie de nos
partenaires allemands qui comptent pour
nous dans se développant dans cette
atmosphère tout à fait positive dans les
milieux d'affaires cela est très utile
pour nous dans la mesure où les
entrepreneurs sont tout à fait disposés
à une amélioration de ce climat d'afflux
beaucoup de propositions qui sont faites
dans ce sens sont étudiées par nos puis
mise en oeuvre concrètement dans nos
mesures économiques
et notre évidemment le secteur
énergétique qui occupent une part
majeure dans ces échanges il y à plus de
70 projets essentiels des
notamment qui concerne
l'approvisionnement de l'europe en
ressources énergétiques de façon suivie
et cela représente un tiers de la
demande allemande avec
35% mais plus de 35 % l'année dernière
l'allemagne
a reçu des livraisons
2,57
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz
et évidemment les déficits de gaz
aujourd'hui en europe dans ces
conditions nous avons continué à assurer
les approvisionnements
sur la base 2 contracte de contrats à
long terme le régulateur
allemand procède actuellement à
l'approbation du projet nord stream 2
qui est aujourd'hui complètement prêt à
entrer en fonctionnement donc c'est un
projet d'infrastructure majeurs pour la
sécurité des approvisionnements
énergétiques
en europe et satisfaire les besoins de
des consommateurs européens tout en
respectant les considérations
économiques comme nous l'avons dit c'est
un projet à caractère économique et qui
ne doit être soumis à aucune
politisation
nous allons poursuivre
le
nous allons poursuivre les
approvisionnements de gaz via l'ukraine
même après 2024 une fois que
le vecteur de north wind sera
complètement opérationnel et cela
restera
opérationnel est avantageux pour tous
les pays partenaires nous voyons de
sérieuses perspectives pour le
développement de la coopération entre la
russie l'allemagne dans d'autres
secteurs que l'énergie c'est le
développement des nouvelles sources
d'énergie nous en avons parlé
aujourd'hui en détails il s'agit aussi
de l'hydrogène par exemple et donc le
dialogue sur tous ces sujets ne se fait
aujourd'hui régulièrement sur la base
des groupes de travail spécialisés nous
sommes aussi intéressés par le
partenariat avec l'allemagne en matière
de préservation du climat et les
propositions émanant de la russie dans
le renforcement pour le renforcement des
mesures de préservation
et tout cela était examinée et la
technologie de réduction des rejets de
gaz à effet de serre à effet de serre a
été justement étudiés nous avons
également
abordé la question des échanges de
culturel universitaire et notamment sur
des programmes de des programmes de
recherche scientifique des programmes
d'enseignement et le forum des sociétés
civiles entre russo allemand se poursuit
il ya des initiatives émanant de la
russie qui ont été proposées et nous
comme vous le savez la russie a demandé
aux états unis à l'otan des garanties de
sécurité
nous en avons parlé aujourd'hui nous
avons parlé aussi des exigences des
revendications importantes que la russie
propose demande sur ce plan c'est à dire
le non déploiement d'armes offensives
aux frontières de la russie la non
extension de l'otan
vers l'est et le retour à la situation
telle qu'elle était entre l'otan et la
russie en 1997 la russie ne peut pas
fermer les yeux sur le fait que les
états unis et l'alliance nord-atlantique
interprète de façon tout à fait libre et
pour en leur faveur les accord qui a été
conclu dans beaucoup de documents
internationaux
il s'agit pas seulement de l'ag libre
choix de choisir les alliances
militaires pour assurer sa propre
sécurité
et comme le répète nos collègues mais
aussi ne pas renforcer sa sécurité aux
dépens des autres pays en même temps
l'otan se réfère à sa politique de la
porte ouverte et nous savons que cet
article
10 et j'en avais déjà parlé dans ma
conférence de presse avec différents
partenaires européens ici le gardien de
qui a été dit évidemment on peut inviter
d'autres pays l'autre l'otan peut
inviter d'autres pays mais encore une
fois c'est tentative de contenir la
russie présente une menace directe pour
la sécurité nationale etc pour l'apa
c'est pour cette raison que nous
voudrions qu'il y ait des obligations
juridiques contraignantes
et nous attendons nous avons donc
les réponses qui ont été fournis par les
états unis et l'otan mais elles ne
répondent pas complètement à ce que nous
avons demandé mais comme l'a rapporté
hier le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères il ya quand même certaines
dispositions qui non seulement nous ne
sommes pas contre le fait d'en discuter
mais en plus c'est ce que nous avions
proposé à une époque les dernières
années en matière de sécurité européenne
en matière
de définition d zarma portée
intermédiaire et de transparence sur ce
et nous sommes tout à fait prêts à des
discussions
nous sommes prêts aussi à
discuter
à dialoguer mais toutes les questions
qui ont été comme ce gel est double je
les dis précédemment se doivent pas être
étudiée dans l'optique que des
préoccupations que la russie a défini
comme priorité dans ce contexte dans la
situation autour de règlement du conflit
ukrainien on sait que les autorités de
kiev se refuse à remplir leurs
obligations des accords de minsk de 2015
et même lors des autres sommets du
format normandie qui ont été conclus
ultérieurement à berlin et à moscou et à
paris encore une fois il ya la question
de l'amnistié des élections locales les
aspects juridiques du statut de dom
basse et la législation ukrainienne n'a
toujours pas entériné ce qui avait été
proposé par le président actuel de la
république fédérale d'allemagne et qui
était à l'époque ministre des affaires
étrangères mais ce stade mayer et donc
c'était un compromis justement pour
l'exécution des accords de metz
malheureusement cela n'a toujours pas
été entérinés par les autorités de kiev
donc la
restauration du de l'intégrité
territoriale du pays doit se faire par
anne via un dialogue direct avec les
autorités de lougansk et de donation or
aujourd'hui il y a toujours le des
infractions aux droits de l'homme
notamment dans le non respect de la
population russophone en ukraine nous
avons parlé aujourd'hui de la question
du nucléaire iranien nous sommes en
contact tout à fait régulier avec les
autorités allemandes et ici nos
positions sont assez proches et pour
conclure je tiens à remercier monsieur
le chancelier fédéral pour le travail
fait en commun et le dialogue tout à
fait approfondies je vous remercie pour
votre attention
mesdames et messieurs
il est important très bien d'avoir cette
opportunité d'assister j'aime ce coup je
remercie pour l'accueil chaleureux pour
les négociations substantielles vous
avez déjà entendu
le précédent poutine a dit qu'il nous
n'avons pas omis dont seul problème des
relations bilatérales des relations
internationales ce qui est très
importante parce que nos juges sont de
par les autres nos pays ont des liens
très profonds et être et
multidimensionnelle c'est que des mots
ce qui est prouvé par
90 villes jumelées les échanges
culturels et entre le jeune assez animé
une 1000 et événements dans plusieurs
dizaines de villes ont ouvert plusieurs
vecteurs d'intro coopération écologie
développement durable
diversité des genres notre coopération
économique et dispose d'un potentiel
important vous vous l'avez déjà entendus
en ce concerne des sujets aussi
importants que des organisations les
ressources renouvelables ou au
numérisation notre responsabilité pour
les changements climatiques ne peut être
assumée que ensemble il est important
que dans les relations entre leurs
genoux l'allemagne à la russie ce sujet
et reste
non portant pour l'avenir en ce qui
concerne le secteur énergie qu'il est
important de trouver dans le monde que
sur notre du pan de vue
d'émissions de carbone trouver notre
place il faut animer le dialogue entre
la société qui a apporté sa contribution
pour
leur demander relations entre deux pays
après la seconde guerre mondiale et
c'est très important c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous avons mentionné le
dialogue et saint pétersbourg qui sert
pendant plusieurs années le symbole de
la compréhension entre nos deux pays
c'est pourquoi je lance mon espoir que
durant les futures négociations au plus
haut niveau notre vont les
sorties des bleus vu céder ans passés il
faut continuer le dialogue pour que tout
le monde puisse y participer et trouver
des solutions c'est avec la
préoccupation que nous voyons que la
société civile est de moins en moins de
place pour leurs activités c'est un
partenaire comme mémorial par exemple
aux autres
en allemagne on n'a pas compris pourquoi
mémorial tu es obligé d'arrêter son
activité
c'est vraiment là
l'organisation qui a contribué largement
à voir clair l'histoire et le sort de
multiples citoyens russes est ramenée de
force aux allemands pour des travaux
forcés
j'espère que de chevet les pourra
poursuivre son activité
des journalistes
ont large spectre des
relations bilatérales a été discuté nous
n'avons pas éviter les points épineux ma
visite est
réalisée au contexte d'une crise très
importante peut-être la plus importante
des creuseurs en europe depuis plusieurs
décennies le la concentration des
troupes russes à la frontière
ukrainienne après les discussions de ce
sujet a pris beaucoup de place dans
notre
grand notre entretien nous avons aussi
parlé des garanties de sécurité exigées
par les rues si moi je donnais mon
appréciation de la situation sécuritaire
et de notre vision d'une ouïe de nos
partenaires européens de cette situation
ce qu'ils ressentent comme à une minasse
ce cette concentration des troupes et du
matériel militaire nous sommes très
préoccupés de jouarres cent mille
militaires être massé à près de la
frontière au créneau sans une cent ans
résumant
concrètes il faut trouver la solution au
pour assurer la décalade est dans cette
situation est très important d'éviter le
commencement de la guerre durant notre
entretien au président pauthe il m'a
fait part de ses consultations avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères et de
la défense il en a parlé je suis
d'accord avec le fait que les
impossibilités diplomatiques ne sont pas
être épuisées pour le moment maintenant
elle est important de vrai avec
persévérance à résoudre cette crise nous
avons entendu des déclarations de que
certain détachement or
reprennent leur
pauvre zones de déploiement permanent
nous nous en réjouissons il est
important aussi de poursuivre les
négociations avec nos alliés de l'otan
nous visons à renforcer la sécurité
commune le temps a déjà à proposer le
format des négociations au niveau du
conseil russie otan dans le cadre de le
laisser
ou la pologne assure la présidence
tournante en animant le dialogue au
sommet c'est ce dialogue sera animée au
niveau de long 30 mutuel et la
reconnaissance mutuelle des principes
concertée par les partis par les membres
de l'essai on y trouve le danger qu'ils
étaient des frontières à la
l'intégrité territoriale de tous les
états y compris le cren ce sont le sujet
qui ne nécessite pas de discussions
ultérieures allons parler d'un problème
dans le cadre de dialogue ne devons pas
nous mettre dans l'impasse qui pourrait
se transformer en un grand bal a une
grande valeur pour nous tous pour le
gouvernement fédéral est évident et les
évidents que l'agression contre leclerc
engendra les conséquences du haut du
pont d'yeu politique économique et il
m'a semblé
que tout le monde le connaît c'était
évident cette escale à sion c'est
doit être à éviter de toute ma force la
recherche de solution diplomatique
c'est l'une des causes majeures de ma
visite à kiev d'hyères et de ma visite
d'aujourd'hui à moscou je suis pas
persuadé que le format normandie
ensemble avec les négociations d entre
la russie et les etats unis est votre
allié de temps serviront des formats
essentiel pour a trouvé la solution il
est faux de l'avancement il nous faut du
progrès alors je me réjouis en fait que
hier le président zelensky m'a promis
fermement
dans le cadre du groupe tripartite de
contact ac qui est fonction dans le
cadre du processus de minsk en
réunissant toutes les parties du conflit
on suivra plus prochainement tous les
projets de loi a prévu concernant les
modifications de la constitution la
préparation des élections c'est un bon
avancement et nous espérons voir les
fruits j'ai demandé le président haut
pour monde donne t elle les négociateurs
de sa part
des
capacités supplémentaires afin
d'atteindre le résultat
pour les européens pour les allemands il
est évident que la sécurité un fiable ne
peut pas être construite alors détriment
de la russie ça doit être fait ensemble
avec la russie il faut trouver ensemble
la solution si compliqué que soit cette
tâche je ne trouve pas qu on est déjà
dans l'impasse il faut vrai avec audace
et avec responsabilité
je dois dire que pour ma génération la
guerre en europe et temps pensable il
faut faire de manière que ça reste pour
les générations à venir notre
responsabilité comme des chefs des
gouvernements et des états il faut
éviter une escalade militaire en europe
merci maintenant on va commencer la
conférence de presse conjointe entre le
président russe et le chancelier fédéral
de l'allemagne les journalistes pourront
poser des questions pour chaque partie
la première question va être posée par
nos invités allemands
may cry kovner dolci velez
monsieur poutine vous avez produit halal
en même temps le signal de vouloir en
dialogue vous avez dit que vous étiez
capable de dialogue et dans le même
temps vous critiquez vous dites que le
chancelier n'a pas apporté assez dans
son bagage qu'une seule promesse
deuxième ce qui ne suffit pas
et que tous les européens
se pose pose des questions malgré les
liens étroits avec les russes il y aura
une guerre en europe excluez-vous une
possibilité de guérir en europe et
monsieur le chancelier fédéral la
question pour vous comment évaluez-vous
actuellement la situation après les
échanges que vous avez eue
il ya t'il des progrès comme vous les
avez attendu et quelle devrait être la
démarche est proche
un
propos de la guerre en europe comme l'a
dit le monsieur le chancelier
pour sa génération et je me rapporte à
cette même génération on a du mal à
imaginer à une guerre en europe
et en l'appliquant à la situation autour
d'eux le cren nous avons été
témoins d'une guerre qui a été
déclenchée en europe contre la
yougoslavie
avec des frappes à coups de missiles sur
une capitale européenne belgrade
ça a bien existé cela il ya eu aucune
aucune sanction du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu
c'est un très mauvais exemple
mais toujours est il qu'il a été ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose est ce que nous voulons ou pas
cette guerre bien sûr que non et c'est
justement pour cette raison que nous
avons été obligés de proposer des
discussions dont le résultat aurait dû
être des garanties de sécurité pour tous
y compris pour notre pays
malheureusement et je l' ai déjà dit
il n'y a pas eu de réponse
circonstanciée
là dessus nous n'avons nous ne l'avons
pas reçue et nous partons du principe
que
dans les documents
qui nous ont été envoyées par nos
partenaires
des pays de l'otan et de washington il y
a des idées qui peuvent être discutés et
nous ne sommes prêts à le faire
que
si que prise
conjointement avec l'ensemble des
questions qui nous préoccupent
en
espérant gelé dit à monsieur le
chancelier en espérant donc ce dialogue
se fera dans cette optique alors comment
cela havas
va se faire est-ce que cela va
comprendre l'ensemble des sujets de
préoccupation qui vous préoccupent et
qui nous préoccupe autant que vous je
vous l'assuré on verra
je pense que dans le contexte actuel il
est important de profiter de toutes les
possibilités
sans laisser à part une seule la
capacité possibilité d'assurer le
développement pacifique de la situation
du
maroc les rations que nous croyons le
processus de minsk et une promise
importante au futur avancement de la
situation se forment des projets de loi
qui devrait être présenté le
la reprise des contacts dans le cadre du
groupe tripartite est aussi important
qui nous servira de point important de
départs pour trouver la solution
pacifique agne cren de ce différend
entre dun basse et le gouvernement du
pays ce qui est important pour moi ce
qui est les négociations au doivent être
réalisés au sein du groupe tripartite ne
contacte a conformément aux accords de
mise que nous avons sont dans le sujet
en yougoslavie c'était situation un peu
différente là on a une
menace de génocide et il a fallu
l'interdire je suis très content que
maintenant c'est le développement
pacifique et que les peuples des balkans
on trouvait des perspectives en plus le
vecteur de développement sont de l'union
européenne
alors ce qui passe aujourd'hui donc d'en
bas c'est précisément génocide
ria novosti marie avec les bovins j'ai
une question concernant large nombre de
questions monsieur le chancelier bourg
venait de revenir de kiev où vous avez
rencontré monsieur zelensky à votre avis
est-ce qu'ils louent qui elle veut et
entend respecter les accords de minsk
dans la forme
dans laquelle ils ont été construits
quelles sont les perspectives du
règlement pacifique monsieur poutine
aujourd'hui nous avons entendu la
nouvelle sur le retrait partiel des
forces militaires et après nous avons
reçu de nouvelles de la demande et à
l'est les députés vont saisie en
demandant de reconnaître la république
de donetsk de lougansk pourriez-vous
donner votre commentaire et je voudrais
aussi posé la question sur les
perspectives de nord stream 2 les deux
leaders concernant les tensions qui
existent et compte tenu des menaces qui
ont été faites concernant ce projet est
encore question monsieur poutine
permettez moi excusez moi de poser
autant de questions votre ami de longue
date monsieur schröder fait partie des
candidats du conseil
d'administration de gazprom il a été
critiqué à ce sujet que pourriez-vous
dire
à leurs premiers points
les élections à la douma
donc on justement juste avant de la
conférence de pre sont mes collègues de
l'administration présidentielle m'ont
transmis des informations et notamment
aux si le retrait des troupes des zones
d'exercice en ce qui concerne les
organes exécutifs
du ps il n'y a rien à
commenter donc il ya eu une décision qui
a été prise sur le retrait des troupes
donc les élections à la douma bien sûr
ça peut être
lié
par dont le vote à la douma sûr
donatello gasc il faut s'orienter sur la
pensée sur les humeurs des électeurs et
dans notre pays c'est clair que là
l'écrasante majorité des gens ex-pro
épreuve de la compassion pour les
habitants de lougansk de donetsk et
espère que cette situation
va changer radicalement
et c'est évident donc il ya eu deux
projets de loi qui ont été proposés
celui de du parti russie unie était plus
important il y avait un autre notre
proposition de loi qui avait été fait
qui émanait d'une demande des
des populations des deux régions
concernées le vote était plus direct
donc
hélas la
discipline des parties a pas ag mais
en fait c'est la proposition émanant du
parti communiste qui a été respectée qui
a été voté nous partirons du principe
que
il faut faire pour que le problème du
dôme bas soit résolu mais il faut le
faire comme l'a dit monsieur le
chancelier fédéral avant tout
sur la base des vases des possibilités
et des accords de minsk qui n'ont pas
encore été mises en oeuvre en espérant
que nos partenaires
outre atlantique et en europe c'est à
dire la france et l'allemagne pourront
exercer une influence suffisante sur les
autorités de kiev pour qu' une solution
ce sens soit adopté après en ce qui
concerne monsieur schröder et le nord
stream 2
j'en ai parlé aujourd'hui à monsieur le
chancelier au début des années 2000 nous
nous étions mis d'accord
avec l'ukraine
qui était alors présidée par monsieur
koutchma
le gouvernement allemand était
représentée par monsieur schröder et la
russie par votre humble serviteur
et nous avions nous étions mis d'accord
pour mettre en place un consortium
international tripartite avec peut-être
éventuellement d'autres partenaires
européens est ce qu'au sort consortium
qui aurait donc diriger l'activité
gazière de le cren non pas pour les
prendre dans sa poche mais pour laisser
sa la disposition du gouvernement de
kiev et développer ses infrastructures
notamment son plan de la maintenance
technique
ensuite les nouvelles autorités
de kriens où l'autorité de iouchtchenko
ont refusé d'exécuter tout cela
au souverain sous prétexte de la
sécurité
des approvisionnements et à ce moment là
monsieur schröder a proposé de soutenir
nord stream
est aujourd'hui lalleman par north
stream 1 reçoit déjà 55 millions de
mètres cubes par an
et là c'est sur la base d'un contrat à
long terme et je le déjà dit
et qui quand les prix spot en europe
sont donnés la un tarif qe 3 4 5 fois
moins cher que les prix spot d'europe
aujourd'hui donc regarder aller consoler
consommateurs les consommateurs
individuels les consommateurs dé les
entreprises qui est ont donc le gaz
russe et regarde ces cinq fois moins
cher aujourd'hui
donc est-ce que vous êtes prêts
aujourd'hui vous les consommateurs
européens à payer pour l'électricité
pour le chauffage pour l'occaz d'une
manière générale 5 fois plus cher sinon
alors remercier monsieur schröder parce
que c'est le résultat du travail qu'il a
fait à l'époque en ce qui concerne sa
présence
dans les organes de direction de gazprom
aujourd'hui en europe beaucoup sont
préoccupés par le fait de savoir si les
approvisionnements des ressources
énergétiques russes en europe et en
particulier en allemagne seront assurés
mais je pense que si la décision est
prise que monsieur je dois peut-être
peut faire partie du conseil
d'administration
justement cela permettrait d'avoir un
contrôle
de la part d'un expert indépendant ce
qui est justement monsieur fraudeurs qui
est un homme honnête que nous respectons
et qui
avant tout aura l'objectif de défendre
les intérêts de son propre pays à savoir
à l'allemagne et par conséquent
l'allemagne et
l'europe auront la possibilité d'avoir
une influence sur la décision de gazprom
et en même temps d'avoir des
informations objectives je pense que ça
ne peut qu'être bénéfique pour notre
coopération et c'est un motif de ce jeu
et donc je pense que cette élection se
désignation doit se faire au mois de
juin et donc à gazprom et il ya
différents experts neutres et notamment
lioran dessus chaudat en ce qui concerne
nord stream 2
c'est évidemment une gestion habituelle
pour eux
il ya eu nord stream 1 et no swing de
dos qui a
il y à la partie financement avec cinq
entreprises
différents dont deux qui sont allemandes
et aujourd'hui encore une fois le
gazoduc nord stream ii est prêt à
l'exploitation techniquement il est prêt
mais pour l'instant il ya le régulateur
allemand allemand qui doit prendre une
décision
sur les approvisionnements par cette
voie de communication
la première question était sur des
accords de minsk tout le monde doit
respecter ces accords ça concerne le
gouvernement de l'ukraine et évidemment
ça concerne la russie l'allemagne la
france
qu'ils participent à ce processus police
politique alors ils sont très importants
pour que tout le monde apporte sa
contribution
d'une côté il faut présenter les projets
de lois nécessaires pour poursuivre les
négociations visant à résoudre ces trois
missions essentielles dont j'ai parlé au
début de mon intervention lie avec le
statut particulier avec les élections la
déclaration de la formule de scanner et
évidemment avec eux les questions liées
à l'amendement de la constitution
ces documents doivent être présentés et
en format tripartite entre la russie
l'ukraine et le essayé avec la
participation d'autres parties
concernées on discutera d'acetex nous
sommes mis d'accord à ce sujet là tout
le monde doit prendre doit encourager ce
processus ce n'est pas le freiner
évidemment on peut interpréter
différemment
mais tout est écrit noir sur blanc tout
est mis sur papier y nous sommes mis
d'accord qu il nous faut beaucoup de
discussions mais ça sera notre pas
suivant telle est notre volonté aussi et
tout les premiers sont déjà faits si
tout le monde se reprennent elles assuré
pont et fait ce pas on réussira ça
signifiera que si le parlement
aujourd'hui adopte
ce qui a été proposé ce sera les
réalités ça pourrait être considérée
comme la violation des accords de minsk
assassiné ferrat l'arrêt du processus
est une vraie catastrophe politique
ce n'est qu'en reprenant les accords de
minsk en les respectant
que nous pourrons progresser et là les
accords de minsk sont assénées en ce qui
concerne à nord stream 2
je ne veux pas donner des commentaires à
l'activité économique d'un ancien haut
responsable qui agit maintenant en son
titre personnel et non pas en tant que
l'ex haut fonctionnaire de l'état en ce
qui concerne le
pipeline des plis la pipe line nous
avons pris les engagements de sueur et
les le transport de
gaz à travers plusieurs pays et nous
devons les respecter nous voulons
attendre
comme résultat ce qu'est l'europe pour
poursuivre son développement
pacifique et sans confrontation
quelque part notamment en ukraine ce
conflit sur dur en conséquence c'est
clair pour tout le monde nous savons que
faire dans ce cas et j'espère que tout
le monde comprend ce qui se passe
comprends les réalités politiques qui
pourraient voir le jour dans ce cas
maintenant il s'agit en fait de
d'interdire ce vecteur de développement
en misant sur le développement pacifique
en faisant preuve de de capacité des
leaders politiques pour sauvegarder la
paix et y faire notre contribution c'est
ça notre
mission
merci beaucoup monsieur le chancelier
la question est pour vous vous avez
mentionné
que des sujets difficiles des relations
bilatérales ont été évoqués vous avez
parlé du mémorial du las de la vague
mais il ya aussi la ferme à malibu savez
qu'aujourd'hui a commencé le procès
il y à
des cyberattaques contre l'allemagne il
ya d'autres choses avez vous évoqué cela
et comment a réagi le président poutine
comment pourriez vous décrire en général
l'état des relations russo allemandes
monsieur poutine
concernant les premiers pas dans le
cadre du retrait des forces armées
quelle sera la situation dans les
semaines à venir est ce que le retrait
va se poursuivre
pourriez vous exclure la tacc contre
l'ukraine aujourd'hui et encore une
question
concernant l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'otan
le chancelier scholz tout comme d'autres
chefs d'état et de gouvernement des pays
de l'otan ne sont pas prêts à donner des
garanties que le cren ne sera jamais pas
partie de l'otan n'accédera jamais à la
tam et
peut-être vous pouvez faire en mode rate
orium
par exemple dans les années à venir
cette adhésion on dit qu'elle est irréel
nous avons mentionné de ne me sujet nous
avons discuté en ce qui concerne l'aval
ni ma position est tout à fait maître
clair
les conclusions faites dans son dossier
ne sont pas conformes aux standards de
troie d'un état
en ce qui concerne
notre invité à la possibilité de ne pas
répondre aux questions la première chose
comment la russie va agir ensuite
selon ses plans
et de quoi vont
être constituées ces plans qui peut
répondre à la question de savoir comment
dans les circonstances actuelles les
choses vont cependant on ne sait pas
personne ne le sait ça ne dépend pas que
de moi mais nous avons la tension et
nous allons chercher à faire en sorte
que nous puissions nous entendre avec
nos partenaires sur les questions qui
ont été posées par non pour qu'elle soit
résolue diplomatiquement
lesquelles elles sont c'est connu c'est
les garanties de sécurité pour la russie
la non expansion de l'otan vers l'est
le retour à la situation de 1997 et le
non déploiement d'armes offensives à nos
frontières tout est clair
nous sommes prêts à parler aussi
d'autres questions
qui sont inclus dans les réponses que
nous avons reçues mais l'ensemble de ces
questions
par mail pour nous ce sont les questions
prioritaires ensuite en ce qui concerne
la deuxième partie de votre question
c'était
j'ai griffonné quelques choses et
j'arrive pas à me relire
en fait ma question concerne et le
retrait des forces et des troupes pose
de la frontière à couillet lors de
l'élargissement de l'otan le retrait des
troupes oui je le dis dans cette partie
j'ai déjà répondu en ce qui concerne
l'extension de l'otan vous avez dit une
phrase remarquable on dit que les années
prochaines là le cren ne serait pas dans
l'otan ou 10 qui dit ça il paraît qu'ils
disent
qu'est ce que ça signifie il paraît dans
les relations internationales ça fait 30
ans qu'on nous dit qu il paraît qu'il
n'y aurait pas d'extension de l'otan
vers l'est vers les frontières de la
fédération or aujourd'hui on voit les
structures de l'otan directement nos
portes et donc la question de
l'intégration de
le cren dans l'otan on nous dit que
c'est pas demain alors c'est après
demain qu'est ce que ça change pour nous
dans la perspective historique ça change
rien en fait
nous entendons dire que le cren n'est
pas prête aujourd'hui à intégrer l'otan
nous connaissons cette thèse et on nous
dit en même temps que de mal ne sera pas
adoptée mais elle sera adoptée à ce
moment là où elle se bat mais peut-être
que ce sera trop tard pour nous par
conséquent nous voulons résoudre cette
question maintenant
maintenant tout de suite très
prochainement au cours d'un processus de
dialogue de discussion de discussion
pacifique et nous souhaitons que nos
préoccupations soient entendues de nos
partenaires est prise au sérieux
bonjour première question pour monsieur
poutine hier lors de notre entretien
avec monsieur lavrov vous avez validé la
réponse au sujet des garanties pour la
russie et vous avez été d'accord qu'il
ya des perspectives pour des
négociations cela veut-il dire que la
russie va passer à un régime de
négociations prolongées de plusieurs
années compte tenu du fait que
washington l occident rejette les trois
principales éléments de
nos initiatives deuxième question pour
les deux et comme je représente ici rt
je ne peux pas ne pas se poser cette
question concernant l'interdiction de
diffusion de leurs thèmes de hitch en
allemagne y at il un moyen de progresser
dans cette question de faire quelque
chose de constructif
avant tout pour régler la question
peut-être qu'on pourrait créer un groupe
de travail conjoint pour qu'on puisse
continuer la diffusion en allemagne et
de tuer la russie à son tour
en ce qui concerne
d'autres cheval comme nous en avons
parlé win avec monsieur le chancelier
fédéral nous avons parlé aussi de la
question de d2 schwaller en russie et de
rt en allemagne
aujourd'hui il a maintenant je voudrais
pas entrer dans les détails pour ne pas
compliquer la situation mais nous sommes
mis d'accord sur le fait que nous allons
chercher une solution à ce problème ça
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
en ce qui concerne
le caractère prolongé des discussions
qui peuvent finalement ne me neri c'est
justement pour ça que hier nous en avons
parlé avec le ministre des affaires
étrangères et aussi avec les
représentants du ministère de la défense
évidemment nous avons cette
préoccupation
la difficulté c'est que
nous avons des craintes
que le processus de discussions sur les
thèmes que nous avons proposé et qui
sont pour nous des questions
essentielles en matière de sécurité peut
être prolongée sans motif par nos
partenaires et à ce moment là pendant ce
processus des décisions seront prises
qui vont aggraver notre
situation et même aggravé de façon très
préoccupante
comme on l'a vu au cours de toutes les
années qui ont précédé et bien entendu
c'est ce que nous avons à l'esprit nous
le comprenons
nous allons en discuter avec nos
partenaires mais en tout cas il y a des
choses que nous n'admettrons pas
tout d'abord
la première question que vous avez posé
au nez un état de droit il faut
déposer des demandes s'était pas encore
le cas ensuite ces demandes devront être
traités par des organismes compétents
confirmant aux lois en vigueur
qui sont les mêmes pour tous
dans un état de droit nous avons des
procédures et des promises pour les
réalisations doivent être à créer ça en
ce concerne le sort de woerth et belge
en ce qui concerne les négociations les
différends persistent c'est pourquoi
notre entretien a duré si longtemps
l'important c'est de se parler
l'important c'est que le temps et
l'union européenne ont donné leur
réponse aux lettres
envoyées par la russie la russie n'est
pas d'accord avec les réponses mais a
trouvé quelque chose de positif
d'encourageant et les propositions qui
ont été formulées par les rues si le
temps est
l'union européenne ne sont pas d'accord
non plus avec ces propositions mais là
on a trouvé des points à discuter
maintenant elle est important d'éviter
une situation dangereuse à chacun doit
savoir qu on assistait déjà d avancement
important à trouver des points de départ
pour les négociations commençant par les
solutions visant à résoudre la crise
ukrainienne le processus et qui est
réalisé qui doit être respecté par tous
les parties prenantes il faut voir de la
volonté à se parler ce concerne les
différences des points de vue concernant
l'élargissement de l'otan le situation
est un peu bizarre
l'élargissement n'est pas planifié n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour n'est pas prévu
tout le monde le connaît c'est le sujet
on n'aura pas la faire à cela
je pense que durant notre mandat
présidentiel est le mien des chanceliers
nous n'aurons pas à faire à ce problème
je ne sais pas combien au monologue et
restera à son poste
moi non plus je sais pas pour moi même
mais je pense que ce ne sera pas notre
problème maintenant il faut assurer que
personne ne refuse de ses engagements l
faut assurer l'énergie politique et
comment pour assurer le développement
pacifique et la coopération en europe on
en parle toujours lorsqu'il s'agit des
questions importantes de sécurité de
coopération en europe de la transparence
de contrôle des armements les demandes
sont formulées le temps a répondu d'une
façon positif c'était pas la réponse que
l'autre côté aurais tu aimé mais il faut
on peut monter en profiter pour en sert
de base à notre responsabilité
la conférence de presse est terminée